im zentrum unserer galaxie der
milchstraße gibt es ein extrem
mysteriöses objekt es ist eine
ungewöhnliche unglaublich große materie
ansammlung die wahrscheinlich irgendwie
mit dem supermassereichen schwarzen loch
im zentrum unserer galaxie zu tun hat
könnte es ein kosmischer string sein
ein extrem massereiches objekt in form
eines superdünnen fadens jetzt ist es
erstmals gelungen ein hochauflösendes
foto zu machen
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommen es jetzt in 26
werken mit allen fakten zu dem
mysteriösen objekt und was es sein
könnte und wie es vielleicht auch mal
wieder die dunkle materie in frage
stellen könnte herzlich willkommen
der astronom farhat josef sade aus
chicago war es der die ungewöhnliche
materie ansammlung im zentrum der
milchstraße 2016 entdeckt hatte ein
filament so werden große
zusammenhängende strukturen im universum
genannt fiel um ist lateinisch und
bedeutet faden und diese materie
ansammlung sind tatsächlich aus
fadenförmigen verbindung aufgebaut es
ist wohl 2,3 licht jahre lang und krümmt
sich um das schwarze loch namen
sagittarius stern im zentrum der galaxie
mit hilfe einer neuen methode konnte
jetzt erstmals ein wirklich
hochauflösendes bild von diesem objekt
gemacht werden zitat das foto zeigt uns
das parlament aus den schwarzen loch
entstehen muss so einer der beteiligten
forscher mark morris von der university
of california doch wie ist es konkret
entstanden darüber gibt es bereits drei
theorien der ersten idee nach könnte das
filament durch superschnelle teilchen
verursacht werden
diese werden wohl aus dem schwarzen loch
geschleudert doch wenn gas ins schwarze
loch gerät kann ein vertikales
magnetisches feld in zylinder form
entstehen dass roth irrt in diesem so
entstandenen zylinder produzieren die
beschleunigten teilchen strahlung dabei
denen sie sich um die magnetischen
feldlinien und entfernen sich vom
schwarzen loch dieses szenario würde für
astronomie teams die erkenntnis bedeuten
dass das magnetische feld in solch einer
umgebung nicht chaotisch sondern
gleichmäßig ist eine beeindruckende
erkennen die zweite theorie ist gleich
noch
mate spannender denn bei dem parlament
könnte es sich auch um einen kosmischen
string handeln also ein extrem dünnes
objekt mit masse und elektrischer ladung
bisher ist das aber ein theoretisches
konstrukt ein string konnte bisher noch
nicht entdeckt werden
doch in der theoretischen physik nimmt
man an dass solche kosmischen strings
existieren und sich in richtung eines
galaktischen zentrums bewegen sobald er
sich dem er eigenes horizont nähert
könnte es also dieser string vom
schwarzen loch verschlungen werden falls
sie sich also tatsächlich um einen
string handelt wäre dass die allererste
entdeckung eines drinks überhaupt wow
ein solcher string ist ein absolut
wahnsinniges objekt es hätte einen
durchmesser der es nahezu eindimensional
macht der trillion sste teil des
kleinsten atoms das wir kennen des
wasserstoffatoms und sein gewicht wäre
exorbitant bei einer länge von sechs
kilometern würde ein solches zwingen so
viel wiegen wie die erde
bei einer länge aber von 2,3 lichtjahren
wären es rund 4,7 millionen sonnenmassen
moment 4,7 millionen sonnenmassen
das ist ja sogar mehr und jetzt 8 und
festhalten als unser zentrales schwarzes
loch gitarrist stern haben soll nämlich
vier millionen sonnenmassen soll die
masse dort sein das ist wirklich
ziemlich verrückt und ich erinnere mich
mehr wieder daran dass die teilchen der
dunklen materie immer noch nicht
gefunden wurden und solche extremen
massen natürlich auch wieder dazu
beitragen die fehlende masse vielleicht
doch woanders zu finden wahnsinn ja und
der dritten theorie zufolge könnte die
anordnung und die position des filaments
zu dem schwarzen loch auch ein
kosmischer zufall sein
demnach würde es keinen zusammenhang
geben dann wäre es also nur ein filament
wie jedes andere in der galaxie doch
seien wir mal ehrlich sage ich ein
zufall
der soll wirklich eher unwahrscheinlich
ich finde das alles unglaublich spannend
nehmen wir nur mal an das von den
zentralen löchern in den galaxien solche
filamente ausgehen als solche kosmischen
singstar aufzugehen das wäre für mich
echt wieder ein indiz dafür dass die
bisherige theorie von der dunklen
materie die eine ist die noch nicht
bestätigt wurde tatsächlich ein irrtum
schon sehr spannend und diese kosmische
springs das ist auch nochmal spannend
die könnten tatsächlich etwas mit der
stringtheorie zu tun haben 2002 wurden
sie nämlich theoretisch vorhergesagt im
rahmen der stringtheorie am ende der
entstehung unserer vier raumzeit
dimension würden sie im
intergalaktischen maßstab entstehen weil
das ist wirklich irrsinnig jetzt bin ich
wirklich gespannt auf weitere
erkenntnisse dazu gewonnen werden können
denn der theorie nach müsste dieser
string gravitationswellen ausstrahlen
und er müsste die hintergrundstrahlung
verzerren
die entdeckung dieses filaments
jedenfalls spannend forschungsteams
weltweit auf die folter dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher junhui zu aus
cambridge ein teil des nervenkitzels der
wissenschaft ist über einen terium zu
stolpern das nicht leicht zu lösen ist
wir haben keine antwort noch der weg
dorthin ist fasziniert ja wenn er also
nicht verpassen wollte vielleicht wie
vielleicht schon bald die theorie der
dunklen materie umgeschmissen wird dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp bahn schon
bald wird es da nämlich hier ein video
geben und ihr erfahrt dann auch vor
allen anderen von diesem video vorab
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der
redaktion vom krieg zum mitmachen und
themen vorschlagen zb und ja das ist der
direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken dunkle
materie rätsel lösen spielen schwarze
löcher eine rolle ja ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran